welcome Kombat X is set to get even gory
assuming that's possible thanks to the
inclusion of an infamous horror movie
villain although not the infamous horror
movie villain from the last game while
2011 s Mortal Kombat let you play as
Freddy Krueger the upcoming game will
let you embody his nemesis Jason
Voorhees from Friday the 13th mortal
kombat x developer nether realm has
confirmed that the fictional masked
serial killer will be one of four add-on
characters included in the game's combat
pack deal c which is slated to include
iconic guest characters and what the dev
are calling classic combatants that's
classic with a k obviously now the realm
has also unveiled a very short to blink
and you'll miss its trailer showing me
what Jason will look like in the game
followed up by the phrase who's next the
dev also recently revealed that series
staples Johnny Cage molina and sonya
blade will be gearing up the battle as
playable characters when the game
releases on April 14 let me know down in
the comments which fictional character
you'd like to see make an appearance on
mortal kombat x and y stay tuned to gain
spot for more updates